what i always think about i interviewed
chris paul maybe like two years ago
and you're talking about lebron and he
says taylor lebron is the most frugal
person i know he says when we walk into
a place the first thing lebron says is
what's the wi-fi password i don't want
to use my data oh yeah yeah oh yeah i've
seen that a million times in toronto
and like
you know
they talk about like wealth and all that
like sometimes the things you don't see
and for him it's like you know behind
the scenes he he if we're in toronto
right like that drive from
the airport and going through customs to
then getting to our hotel yeah there's
no
there's no data used at all like he's
waiting for the wi-fi all the time and
then so that then that drive from the
hotel to then the arena
uh air canada
also waits for to get to the arena wi-fi
like
that's so funny you know like
what's a
finance great saying uh a small leak can
sink a great ship but like that's like
that's even a minute exactly that's not
even you know it's nothing yeah but but
yeah i can appreciate it yeah i gotta
say it's not like i'm mad at it but i'm
like come on bro like seriously yeah
just get get on wi-fi you wanna like
maybe it's good for you to get away from
your phone for a minute but like
i don't know it's it's just
you know roaming i don't know and i
think you know us keeping in touch
through a group chat where it's
uh six of us on it from our 2016 team
yeah and you all are in it every day
every single day i mean it's constant
and we talk about everything i think
that's the beauty of it um it's
definitely a safe space guys throw out
different things if guys are going
through a moment um we're very
supportive and
again like if somebody needs to get get
clowned or trashed or put you know ran
through the mud we do that as well like
it's all it's all good at the end of the
day